Let's uh let's do a secondary question
to do with this same pair of vectors A
and B so what I'm going to ask this time
is can we find a vector
that is orthogonal
to both of the vectors that we've been
given to both A and B
find a vector that's orthogonal to both
okay now before we actually start doing
this question I just want to point out
it's three-dimensional and it has to be
three-dimensional you can't pose this
question in two Dimensions I wonder if
anyone can tell me why this is
exclusively a three-dimensional question
and it's not allowed to be a
two-dimensional question any any
thoughts
uh both yeah
um
yeah yeah very good okay fantastic so it
is that word both right if we're in 2D
if we're flat on the page right um if I
if I gave you two vectors like here's
one and then I don't know here's another
one right
um it's no problem finding a single
Vector that's perpendicular to either
one so here's perpendicular but it by
definition unless the two original
vectors were parallel it's not going to
be perpendicular to the other one right
these two vectors have to be different
to each other in two Dimensions but
instinctively I wonder if you recognize
in the back of your mind we've been
working with third vectors that are
orthogonal to a pair of vectors quite uh
like even from the very first lesson
because I gave you guys uh the sort of
uh X Y plane and I said hey imagine if
it was sitting flat and then I said now
imagine a third axis right the z-axis
each of the axes can be thought of as a
vector right so can you see the pi
positive z-axis is a vector that's
orthogonal to the X and the Y axes right
so we can do this in three dimensions we
can't do it in two so before we now that
we've sort of noted the unusualness of
this question I'll just shove this to
the side
um how are we going to do this how will
the dot product help us to find this
vector
have a think
ing
zero so you just said to both of them
at the dot product equals zero right
yeah fantastic well done so our third
Vector right who knows what it is in
fact let's define it uh let's uh let's
call this one Ah that's often a
conventional name and I don't know what
it is so let's just call that uh you
know x y z so it has some three mystery
components and when you take the dot
product
um between a and this new Vector are if
those two are perpendicular then COS of
90 degrees is zero so that dot product
should be zero and in the same way when
you do the dot product with B that
should also equal to zero right now what
this is going to give us is if you have
a look at the the left hand side in each
of these cases right these two things
using the component formula for the dot
product it's just going to give us 2 two
equations a pair of equations with x's
and y's and Z's can we just go ahead can
we write those two equations out that
come from here
I'm just going to close the window hold
on
my bell just went
uh what are we gonna get here
where's my vectors going
[Applause]
[Music]
okay let's see whoops
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
so um these are the two equations that
I've got I know I haven't tidied them up
at all but that's okay
I want you to have a look at these two
equations
and I want you to notice
um I spot some problems I spot some
challenges right
two equations I I need to solve some x's
and y's and Z's so I've set them up as
simultaneous equations can anyone spot
what a problem might be as we go about
solving this
you've got two equations to find three
times yeah this is um this is a problem
two equations to find three variables
um as a general thing I don't know if
you've ever been told this before but as
a general property to solve for n
variables you need to have an
simultaneous equations right that's
normally the way things work and I'm one
short right if I wanted to know what X
and Y and Z were unambiguously I'd need
a third equation okay now uh there's a
reason why I can still solve this
problem even without a third equation
just go back to the question again
you remember how we said uh in three
dimensions this word both is an issue
right there's another word in this
question and there really aren't that
many words to choose from there's a
single word in this question that gives
you a clue as to why it's totally fine
that we've only got two equations for
three variables can anyone suggest what
word it might be
yeah that's a bit sneaky right it's this
word a
um find a vector now what's going on
here I know it's such a it's such a
throwaway word you don't pay close
attention to it right when you say find
a vector what that means is well there's
multiple answers right uh and that
should make sense to you because that
example I gave to you before about oh
the the positive Z axis is orthogonal to
the X and Y axis remember that well the
positive z-axis is not the only one
right for example if I just go back over
here there's also for starters oops
sorry there's also the negative z-axis
that's also orthogonal not to mention
the fact that
um along the z-axis you've got an
infinite number of vectors that are all
in that same direction so they're all
orthogonal but you know you could have
one that's a single unit a unit Vector
you could have one that's uh two units
or three or any number right so what
this is telling you is hey there are
multiple answers for this which means
that you are going to be able to find
multiple values of X multiple values of
Y multiple values of Z okay so given
that there are multiple different ways
uh this goes sound a bit strange at
least it was strange when I first
encounter it you actually just need to
pick a value of x or y or Z and then
solve what happens for Y for the other
two components right so there's three of
you in the room this is actually perfect
right I'm going to ask each of you to do
this slightly differently okay so can
one of you say let x equal one and then
solve solve for y and z
can someone else let y equal one and
then solve for x and z and then can the
third person can you let Z equal one and
then solve for x and y can I give you a
moment to do that and obviously if
you've if you're a fast finisher or
maybe you've already started doing this
um before I did
um have a go add another one and see
what you get so let me give you a couple
minutes to work through that okay
done a bit of a um I've done a bit of a
Jamie Oliver and I'm going to give you a
here's one I put
so um you tell me if I've gotten this uh
right as well
when I let x equals one here's what I
got right so I got a y value or I got
the Z Value First in fact and then I've
got a y value so here's here's the
vector I ended up with one five over
four three over four did did that match
yeah okay fantastic uh when I let y
equal one I got this instead I got four
fifths and then one and then
three-fifths yeah yeah yeah okay here's
my last one
um Z equals one I got four thirds Five
Thirds and then and then one okay now I
wonder if you noticed let me Zoom all
the way out right I wonder if you
noticed what the relationship is between
these three different solutions that I
found and I did give you a clue when we
were thinking about the the z-axis
before and that kind of thing
um how would you explain with words how
are these three R's related to each
other
hi this is set in April to each other
can you expand on that a little bit more
what do you mean by set them equal to
each other
like something x equals something y
equals something is there so like for
sure to internal uh okay I see what you
mean yeah all right okay so you do have
this and you might have noticed by the
numerators and denominators on all the
fractions you're like something's going
on here they're all a bit weird right
what you can do is you can say
um if we were to phrase all of these
like look it's gross with the fractions
right so what I'm going to do here is a
way of expressing this R without the
fractions inside is to find an
appropriate scalar factor to divide
through by so that I don't have
fractions in the inside now in this case
because all the fractions are divided by
four I can just take out a factor of a
quarter and then what does that leave me
with on the inside well it'll before
and then five and then three is that
okay
now if you have a look at that right and
now compare that say to the next one
right in this case the scalar factor
that you removed wouldn't be a quarter
it would be
a fifth wouldn't it
yeah but then once you take that out
what do you get in the actual column
you get four five and then three and
then no prizes for guessing if you had a
look at the very last one right you
would take a third out and then what
would you get you would get four and
then five and then three so really these
three answers that we've gotten they're
all just
scalar multiples of the same Vector
they're all facing in the same direction
um and that direction is where the
orthogonalness comes from right you
don't care about the magnitude um you
just care about which which way it's
going okay so I suppose if we were very
very clever we might have chosen four
instead of one because that would have
given us at least for this one would
have given us integer values but I
didn't know that ahead of time before I
started solving so that's okay you still
you still got an answer at the end
yeah okay very good well spotted okay so
um what I would suggest is or what I
would ask is one more question which is
that uh here you remember I said I'll
let x equal one let y equal one let Z
equal one uh this is actually a very
strange choice in a way
um because if you're trying to solve for
things you're trying to eliminate things
there's usually a simpler number that we
choose which makes things easier to
solve like things cancel what's the
other number that you might have chosen
to substitute in
well zero zero right like I love zero
zero is great thank you you can do
Arabic number system for inventing zero
because it makes things like cancel out
so easily but I want you to notice the
problem that emerges maybe we can all do
this together right
um a very significant problem emerges if
you try to let any of the components
equal zero okay Watch What Happens
so say for example let's go to equation
one right you go okay well um substitute
this into equation one you're going to
get zero there's a substitution plus
well I already had zero y so that's zero
and then you've got four Z or take wave
or Z that's equal to zero
um what does that give me for Z
ero that gives me zero and then when you
take x equals zero and Z is equals zero
and you pop them into equation two
um you pretty quickly realize you're
like uh oh this is um this is this is
not a good prize
um I'm getting zeros for everything
right I'm getting the zero Vector now
hold on a second is this a reasonable
answer what do you think
yes why is this a reasonable answer
unpack that for me
it's orthogonal to everything okay there
we go very good so the zero Vector
because it doesn't have any magnitude it
goes in every direction which is a
little bit like here's here's a metaphor
in my head right if you went to the
South Pole if you're in Antarctica
you're standing on the South Pole which
direction is north
and the answer is everywhere is north
right because everywhere you're facing
is is away from South okay now in the
same way or in a similar way the zero
Vector is perpendicular to every other
Vector but that also means the zero
Vector is parallel to every other Vector
so we have a name for this in maths when
we come up with an answer which is
technically true but meaningfully kind
of pointless right we call this a
trivial solution or a trivial case so
it's like yeah I mean it gives you the
dot product you were asking for but it's
also kind of pointless right it doesn't
help you
um remember I said to you before we
learn about what a thing is and then we
say hey what kind of stuff can we solve
with this it's like this doesn't really
solve any problems that I'm interested
in right and so therefore even though it
technically is a solution
um it's it's not a very useful one so we
kind of ignore it okay
so I'm looking at the time let me pause
there
um the whole point of what we were doing
today was to see that the dot product
can be applied to different kinds of
problems today we're focusing on angles
on Friday we're going to go a little bit
further if you remember projections um
in extension one I don't know if your
brain's like oh man that was a confusing
thing to me we're going to expand on
that it's why I didn't want to do it in
this lesson and cram it all in